yes it
eliminate what's up everyone and where's
my audio where's your audio Oh it'll be
back I just wanted to make sure everyone
can hear us there you go it should be
you should be good now Kelly he is in
the middle of an intense call of duty
black ops 4 multiplayer match right now
some stuff something things bad but over
I appreciate it like beep we're here to
watch the cool call of duty gameplay
we're not here intro or talk yeah you
know I realize that I put our hip where
the score is I think that's fine we can
we can move it that's that's what we're
here for
I think is it it's just it's comforting
we could yeah okay fine you move it down
a little bit I'm gonna try to go kill
some people
yeah I'm gonna move it to the upper
right admit you know it's been bad here
I am going through mid Street
well long slide so yeah the slide feels
real real good in this case it's kind of
broke sometimes I feel like though it's
the only yeah oh that is a silencer he
must be a pretty high level your gun oh
yeah he's got dude he he went to work on
this this is the second SMG here so if
he's got a thing here second SMG is like
what 13 13 but like three have a for him
to have a silencer he like it some work
yeah so yeah we're playing call of duty
black ops wars multiplayer beta and
we're here to talk to you guys about I
don't know stuff it's Friday
talk to us let's talk about Call of Duty
let's talk about your weeks how are you
all doing well how do you feel about the
time to kill and like the health pack
stuff that's probably the biggest change
right outside of what some of these Call
of Duty's always kind of been like a big
quick quick to kill kind of thing for me
and I feel kind of weird about how long
it takes now because it makes fights
last longer yeah yeah if you get head
shots of heals fast if someone has body
armor it feels too long
yeah body armor you gotta get that level
5 heck yeah it's really good actually
cuz like you said like for the people
that don't aim for head shots most
people probably I mean some people try
obvio I feel like everyone always tries
but you can't you can't always edge shot
ok but yeah because the body armor
basically gives you like what like 1 or
2 free like oh you hit me twice but it
didn't really do anything yeah wasn't me
oh this guy has this yeah this guy is
pretty highly he's he's into it yeah
that's that's pretty good yeah so you
gotta get pretty high level to get
silencer I think um and that's the GSK I
think yeah how's the gunplay has it has
a gunplay change not necessarily not too
much good I think the biggest change to
the actual like gunplay is having the
ability to heal which is not even a part
of the guns mm-hmm
it's being able to like pull yourself
back to heal whenever you're in the
middle of a fight makes me kind of
change how
approach situations instead of being
like I need to like move around this
corner or go a different way I mean look
at me more tactical I guess because like
I don't know I'm like I've leveled the
[ __ ] out of this gun and like I don't I
don't think it's time to go to that
second SMG I have it but I don't like it
as much
see suppressor is 12 so I'm close and
close we're doing well here nice thank
you for tuning in um somebody asked what
was the most opie gun I don't know what
it is yet I feel though personally its
unless you are really good at quick
scoping I feel like it's still SMG you
life I feel like it's it's smg's to like
sniper rifles I never could get them to
work but I hear people who are actually
good with them or having trouble getting
them to work I don't know man I was
getting quickscope by some guy real bad
last night some people are dedicated to
the quickscope life I also hear rifles
are good but they're not as good I have
funny because like we were playing with
some some of my other friends last night
and they you know they play Cod right so
like they we're trying to you know use a
arse at the beginning and then he's just
like dude what the hell you know you're
just your typical Cod complaining myself
included like like how did this guy get
me I've got this this real strong gun
and then eventually he switched to an
SMG and he's like oh I get how to play
this game now yeah yeah it's like okay
it's everything's just quicker snappier
as soon as you get like the rapid fire I
think you win almost any gunfight even
if someone just been shooting at you
first what's the worst thing about black
ops for um at least personally right now
if it's Cora quarry I wish a ours were
better maybe I just suck with them I
don't know but like it feels like if
you're not using an SMG you're like
gimping yourself excuse me I'm gonna
play torque one more time i I found
torque to be very annoying
yeah he's the shield gun yeah boy is he
annoying here I'll try to use an AR
despite all the stuff I just said that's
why we're in the biz I'm gonna I'm gonna
camp this game yeah I'm gonna camp hard
with so torques abilities is to one the
equipment base thing is barbed wire
which
dude it has so much life it does and it
can also kill someone in like 3 hits yes
their legs wild the crazy thing to me is
just like how much ammo you actually
have to dump into it to get rid of it so
like in theory it's like alright cool
like alright I dare you to come in here
post a camp over here I hope you guys
come this way they're probably not that
person should not put the teleporter
there that is like this is like a
symmetrical role right there that's how
people die they just hit the button to
test it out that's that's what that
looks like the thing is you can actually
spawn differently but people like even
myself we're spawning like dang it
spawning on that thing because it
defaults to that first I think hello do
you think this game is worth $60 I'd say
I've only played the multiplayer side
yeah coming to my bar barbar wire and
then it takes its soaks damage too so if
I was like this and you're trying to
shoot me the other big thing too is the
fact that you have to like let the
person know that you're there because
you're shooting cuz you can't just walk
up to it and destroy it anything as
barbed wire gives you points to your
history or sorcery oh really yeah it's
like 25 each time and if he dies it's
even more I don't know it's something
crazy like that I gotta get back to my
nest it's fine it's the baby so much no
no it's just so much slower than the SMG
yeah promotion Oh how's the medic is
there time oh look at that 75 for for
healing 75 so I haven't gotten a chance
to actually do like the healing as the
medic because the first default thing
that I messed with him with just as deep
no ammo bag and people oh that one's
good too by the way
yellow bag is really good but no one
knows now that you have to like hold the
button to pick it up so no one picks it
up so just so you know with that with
the ammo pack if you um pick it up and
you kill people with it it has to your
source Creek and the other guy gets
scorestreak just from you picking stuff
up so yeah it's it's really really good
but no one knows that you have to hold
the button to do it
dude broast so we've gotta be better
with time but it's really spying
get out of here you see that barbed wire
no he's real
talked about the sweet spot over here
I'm doing the camp in not you here you
want to be real like cheeky even though
that that very very kill but they they
can't get one of my guys has a chopper
gun already yeah people are that's what
you owe you got past a barbed wire
dang no he didn't he just shot me from
oh should you get battlefield 4 I think
there's room enough for both I've only
played the bane of yeah yeah uncle Hill
my barbed wire Oh damnit here to mine
see he had a counter counter to counter
what you had but dude I played a game
where like they had to torques and they
literally like put up like double barbed
wire like you can put up more than one
barbed wire if my once my cool down
comes off that that's what I find it
really and it actually illa yes I feel
like that needs some work like that
should not be a thing I did notice that
as recon I was able to put down a couple
at least put down to recon sensors at
once if I place them really well have
another barbed wire well do you know now
I am literally fortified your title for
black ops 3 is legend of the exo gods
I'm really happy that we're not doing
like exosuits
that slide is like oh god that slides
good but like I don't like like I like
wall running is a concept that's really
cool but I don't know if I like it in
Call of Duty I like I like where we are
with this one did they just like wait
what okay so one of my barbed wire is
gone it's why so maybe it does have like
a time that it just kind of expires but
the fact that you can have two I feel
like it should just be like one and then
like if you place another one it gets
rid of the other one because two just
seems a little too good and it's very
annoying
because like I said it takes forever to
kill if I if they had a torque and I
could show you how long the time to kill
was on one of those things I would but
yeah it's it's long though man I love
the auto aim - it literally pulled me
through the wall that goes a wall hacker
yeah
it's the same scorestreak system yeah
basically cemg the score stays I don't
think the scores stay if you die do you
think oh no no there's one perk there's
one perk that does it I think I didn't
see it Aaron was saying something like
that and I didn't personally see it so I
know oh body armor say what's that body
armor yeah have some barbed wire any
Easter eggs found on any Maps not yet I
feel like it's still kind of early but
maybe people will find some stuff so I
dare you this is my spot now we going up
Todd just joining can you explain what
the barbed wire does it slows people and
damages them if they stay in there long
enough
Oh sniper yes so if you like whip around
a corner and walk into barbed wire it'll
take like three times and you'll die but
it's it's basically just a thing to keep
people out of wherever you are
night bead I was not hurting him enough
it's like a very like Rainbow six siege
yeah they're they're kind of bringing
like the but you can walk around it so I
didn't do a good job of play yeah that's
that's raising it here I'm gonna
challenge this guy and if I regret
everything
oh there's grenades in here there's no
crush so there is created class some
alive but it works within the what are
they called they're not operators or not
specialists there yeah I had to look
that up this more alright whatever word
they decide to use but yeah they they
basically just apply the class over
whatever specialist to choose you're
supposed to challenge
is one more oh they destroyed my thingy
Alex says the health system is nice and
I I kind of like my flyer like it fought
it would be like kind of a weird thing I
like those actually but I like him yeah
hi all right I gotta go over that guy I
got to go around that guy's got your
number I'm just trying to challenge him
what the AR thinking like oh I'll beat
him because skill but clearly no skill
right now I dropped my KP everyone also
cuz I stop camping you're you're warming
up you how many games have you played
today two - exactly
third time's the charm I got my barbed
wire uh how do you get the beta of the
codes Comcast or not Comcast Xfinity
customers got codes yeah um and I think
we're doing a giveaway I'm not sure if
all those codes are gone though on on
the site but definitely check it out
vive wolf lame third man open beta
coming out I don't know I haven't heard
in some ways you can argue this is kind
of open but not really like pre-order
and like Xfinity it's like a limited
access open beta yeah something like
that
I'm sure they'll do an open one at Spa
the dough I'm so sorry Doge I had to do
it you're attacking my teammate I'll
play is someone else who have you been
playing us really recon recon zero unity
that's what we needed
I really like recon
I didn't realize he's you know he's
doing still have the controller stuff oh
how do I turn that off if you hold down
the PlayStation button there is an
option for sounds nothing you just trim
off there I didn't want to go to full
camera while I do it then oh yeah sure
boom it's us again where is this that
sound devices and then you just turn
down that one
the way oh just like that all right
we in there are we back no Lord you guys
didn't miss much of a black screen there
now what do you think about the battle
royale mode get the teaser that we saw I
mean September we'll play it in
September there you go yeah here's a
creative class what did I get
ooh what's an a/b are two to three
tactical rifle here we'll make that
class I know I'm never gonna use that
let's be real here tactical rifle oh is
this like a DMR kind of thing like a
pulse looks like it could be like a DMR
like a yeah cuz the swordfish is like a
pull-up for Bert that's a four burst
this is a three burst semi-auto with
high damage all I never to use that I
give it two round bursts for that sniper
rifle that's kind of cool but Real Talk
everyone's just using smg's yeah I'm not
gonna lie to you guys the meta is smg's
right now it is yeah or quick some quick
scope sniping if you're good at quick
scoping hero play is like recon or
something so yeah looking out recon is
your showcase character though you try
to mix it up who can do crash is really
good as mentioned I like renewing
without profit because profits hilarious
so is the tack the heel so I I think you
have to change from the assault pack
like there's something inside of his
class you can switch around for you're
throwing axe oh there you go it's not
one hit kill it's one hit kill if you're
in the back I think okay there's that
pick 10 system coming through when you
get rid of I'll decide later I've never
been good with the throwing X I do like
that we've we're still keeping the
system where I can just ditch having a
secondary if I want to to like load up
on other stuff yeah that's why I really
like the pick 10 system a lot technical
where I flow sounds like marksman rifles
yeah I guess it's like I don't know
probably like I know cuz like what else
are you gonna call him pulse rifles like
destiny burst rifles yeah
core how much does this game worry about
fortnight I mean it was telling that
Activision like and they come out and
say like oh like we had a good quarter
despite being somewhat like worried
about for tonight I think something like
that no don't
verbatim me but it was something like
that like they had a good quarter
despite being you know concerned you
know of just how big for tonight is like
this is a interesting gun like I'm lying
in this struggle concerned with how big
for tonight is yeah so uh his r1 is like
Hans O's like pulse arrow oh yeah I love
this it's really somewhere and you can
see everyone who comes into the area
it's so good and then his alt is
basically Black Widow yeah oh yeah
that's all right I'll take into that not
gonna complain I will say it's body
armor this thing needs rapid fire and
then goodbye VB yeah
no I I have that really bad habit every
one thing I'll say is like if you're
trying to get into cod just don't reload
until you have to I feel like I reload
way too often and it gets me killed more
often than not when I like could have
fought the guy with like 12 bullets and
I might not have won just don't want to
get like the thing that alleviates that
a bit is if you get like the the
tactical magazines I know they're there
in the first black ops where they're
like tape together and you just flip it
over
yeah that's so that's what crash crashed
gives you that I think really like yeah
yeah when you get his ammo pack thing
okay that's that's good cuz that does
one of my favourite things
you got grips now you've got sights
you're you're doing the thing this is a
base I don't even know what which kind
it was
yeah I think this thing with like
rapid-fire assuming it even has it would
be pretty good
yeah but I'm missing like crazy oh I had
my my sensor my my wall hacks do we know
if this Call of Duty has dedicated
servers or not I don't that I read up on
it so I'm not sure
milady see I'm on fire yikes
and you can't heal when you're on fire
please see that it's man fire yeah I
didn't realize that that's what fire did
dang it yeah I don't know I haven't seen
that oh I did 94 damage come on
sometimes I do 6 but I've seen like the
health bar drop way more I'm like mmm
come on game yeah oh yeah here we go we
got a little Oh see you want to see how
long this takes let's watch don't worry
that was just one clip it's gonna take
two more clip oh okay it worth it it's
not worth it to do it at all that's the
one thing we're all upset about last
night the spawn stuff is kind of not so
great but that's I guess that's typical
card do I say that
there's a lot of yelling how is he
behind me like cuz your your spawns will
just flip so much I know sometimes I'll
literally spawn in front of people who
swooped into our school that we were in
and they'll just shoot me from behind
but it's famous so I don't know oh this
thing does okay so if you can get off to
like kind of like high shots it's pretty
good ruin just dude they're coming
they're coming dude how did you die we
touched on about the new healing system
a little bit earlier I like it I think
it's a really cool yeah it keeps you
more in the moment which had a SMG there
been mmm yeah it would have killed so
many of them doing some science right
now yeah that's true
okay oh wow some guy just got four kills
oh you tried to drop a hot shot get out
of here that's what the people on the
internet say that when you try hard in
your drop shouting you know not about
the drop shot life I do if I can
remember it's a dexterous thing that I
can't always remember stand up and get
shot in the head like anyone else
hello I deserve to die Jesus whiff City
this gun feels okay yeah
I'm not great with it obviously it was
doing better earlier no that guy though
yeah just gotta get headshots Ben just
got a you know always always always
always begin headshots
oh that was way too high I did well it's
fine since it still comes harder for
people that ya see it and they're not
gonna kill it exactly I'm sorry if this
isn't the action you guys want it but
this is how you got a play well this is
the duty man thing this is called duty
in 2018 thanks for white knighting me
we're we're we're here for it we got it
that's why I tell Ben to come on the
streams because I know he'll protect me
it's true
oh oh that's the shock train that's I
thought we call that the Rumba oh god
it's like a free meal unless somebody
act oh okay okay oh wait there's
something that comes out of the chute
yeah it's a heat wave it's like really
good and this thing takes like a lot of
damage to I can't believe this but it's
okay I will commit to the leveling this
gun at least to level two here we can
give everyone all hacks like this
alright yeah give me all the points
give me more points yeah more points
it's great you just kind of exist in it
spams you with see this is really weird
actually getting used to this
please I haven't killed anyone in
forever
oh he's behind me yep mm-hmm
awareness no UAV so absolutely yeah go
ahead
see it doesn't seems a lot of stuff to
counter UAVs besides a counter UAV which
rocket forget a rocket just like one
rocket launcher and I haven't been able
to bring it with me because I just can't
be bothered can't be bothered huh kind
of team player are you the one that's
constantly putting down markers for
everyone know where people are actually
um Wow Eric please
okay guys I got that guy couldn't get
the other guy to save my life when you
hit the headshots though it's real good
Oh double recon is pretty nasty because
you can put double sensor darts out yeah
oh hi
hi pepper dude I saw one there was a
clip yesterday it's which clip where the
dog flew off trying to get someone no he
disappeared into the ether that's not
good at all no it wasn't good definitely
was not a good thing I would have killed
them you were I would have definitely
killed him there we I think we've won
every match we've been in at least so
that's that's pretty good - don't jinx
it oh here's the quad kill I think he
got a quad but these are in a launcher
basically oh yeah so we're scorestreaks
like in this game I'll tell you when I
get something Shh it's the same yeah
it's the same stuff
black ops games were always fails I
don't know about that I like um I went
into I think I still think black ops 1
is probably the best Call of Duty in my
opinion it's fair it's got more content
I really loved the time setting I loved
all the weapons in it I also pointed a
whole bunch oh there isn't there isn't
thing a quick-fire that would've been
really good I guess okay though you get
two different stocks so I need I don't
even need extended you need silencer
that's the other thing that's always
like that stupid meta is like you just
run around and silencer and because you
don't want to show up on the radar yeah
yeah play a different specialist next up
any crash crash is cool dude
I haven't played as a firebreak at all
put on a Oso the core reactor is that
thing that probably burned people and
like makes it so you can't really heal
maybe yeah there's there I haven't
messed around much with people outside
of crap I've been outplayed by the
grapple gun really because I saw him and
instead he was like Co he grappled past
me and then shot me and I couldn't spin
around fast enough and I was like oh all
right well props to you sir
I feel like I can't get behind the the
grapple gun just cuz I don't know
nothing and then nomads got the the Doge
and he can put up a mine so he's decent
at the camping do you need to serifs got
the golden gun and she's got basically
Symetra teleporter so I think she's
gonna be really good on like more
tactical Maps yeah being able to bring
people up and down further up is
definitely because the other thing
people aren't really doing um to be
honest is they're not doing a good job
of killing like equipment oops
do you know what his TAC thing does I've
never used it I'm talking about his uh
his are maybe that is a healing no no
his uh as is are one hour one drops an
ammo bag okay so then what's his l1 r1 I
think that's the healing I know
okay yeah there wasn't a good descriptor
in there yeah is like TAC 5 weapon I'm
like what is attack 5 weapon huh yes
exactly I know what this business and
the other thing I guess certain
specialists don't get their ability
right off the bat this is a bad idea of
better thing was one shot every time but
I thought I was at least my trade world
at war was a really good Call of Duty I
enjoyed that one as well but there's
just the story in black ops 1 yikes
Oh sliding Roy the story the all the
different modes wide an ops arcade which
is really fun I really like the zombie
maps in it I had the president one you
could play as flipping Kennedy like and
put down the ammo pack which is a good
time I guess me every time what are we
looking forward to most in black ops 4
and what do we feel about them ditching
having a campaign I'm looking forward to
that
zombies map on the Titanic because I
kind of kill the thing I used to really
be into like sunken ships when I was a
kid you know boys I got zombies on a
sunken ship so that's really badass
campaign noise I don't feel too bad I'm
curious I don't feel too bad to be
honest I never really played campaign
and I'm pretty sure most people didn't
either but I mean if they were just like
oh it's the Call of Duty multiplayer and
that's it I'd be more concerned but
they're giving us the Battle Royale
giving us zombies like multiplicities
pretty good multiplayer from what we're
playing in the beta I'm curious about
blackout I want to know if it's any good
yeah I am curious how they're working at
definitely yeah
this on the Gameboy this is actually on
the the Gameboy pocket SP now what good
hi hello I was healing he saw me on the
radar but then like was like where is he
when this game launches will to be more
specialist or just the ones in the beta
I I don't know if they're playing on
expanding the specialists per se I feel
like these are the ones we're getting
but don't quote me on that now quote me
on that what play battlefield 1 but the
beta for this is happening now
battlefield 1 came out like complain
yours all wrong plan is all wrong Ben
come get an assault pack its the beta
this is the time when you try out things
without gonna worry about it affect your
your score don't war machine likes I
didn't even see her freaking shoot it I
feel like I got her but you know what
the other thing is um I should realize
is that I feel like with every Cod if
you watch the replays you actually
aren't doing what you think you're doing
sometimes if that makes sense like
there's actually like delay I would play
on PC this is on the ps4 pcs next week
pcs next week oh so ok so I have my alt
I just don't know what it does do I just
do it but does it just give everyone a
frickin oh I mean a he'll there's only
one way to find out
alright oh hi uh yeah everyone's got
more life now I guess accepted guy that
died yeah I guess okay that's pretty
good I don't think my teammates made
yeah the the no one fixing a pair are
you it I don't think we're trying to
make an argument for it I feel like as a
person who's played campaigns and
previous caller duties and is excited to
play this one I can be okay with not
having a campaign not necessarily trying
to say I needs to be gone because no one
played it because people played it
obviously but I think I can deal with
not having it it's not a big deal to me
it's not I always play it for
multiplayer and I only really played
because like some of my friends would
play and they're like hey did you pick
it up oh yeah I guess I will oh man
poo poo yeah what how dare they come on
come on come on come on I know I know
you're in this room you know what's
crazy though is there's no frag grenade
until 29 yeah oh that guy's camping that
guys laying on the floor is this like
the aw but it's futuristic it looks like
a nog but it doesn't look like it
or at least for me when I think of a
Naga I think of like the Augen Counter
Strike where it's like an auto rifle is
that good that guns got a really
interesting sound it sounds like someone
just like slapping mud I don't know if I
like it very much that's not good goods
alright let's die together it's
quickscoping back yeah yeah yeah I'm not
very stoked about that but it hasn't
been too much of an issue yeah but I've
only played for like it yeah it depends
hey I see you Amy
oh goodness
someone make that guy why do I do I go
hey
tough break dude you stuck with me oh
really but we both have hats on oh shoot
oh I get it it's both of us
oh it's right that both of us that's a
joke with the both of us might have been
it oh come on guys it's early on Friday
Yeah right
wait you're not right like what else can
I do if you've won all your games like
that's that's all it is
he's a sniper I don't know if you want
me to use this new gun the mud slapper
yeah man that all think about what I
hear that gun I don't know why it's real
gross so I'll play one more it's guys he
seems pretty good like he seems like
your support like full-on here's more
you know animal bigger clips when you
get this all pack and then if I use my
alt everyone gets more life exactly so
you know no skill-based anything just
drop it oh you're just you're
contributing to the team without having
to worry about anything they have none
of them goddamn loop boxes who the trick
the the tritium site is real good I like
it a lot yeah this one yeah it's a
little more yeah yeah like I want can we
pick ten this so that we get a we want
perk one or three what's in three again
I only got tracker now see digital
imprints let's try that out
oh heck yeah so we just need and then we
need that and then we'll get rid of our
handgun cuz nobody ain't nobody and
engineer your tactical mass is whatever
this is kind of cool
let's you see all the like traps and
stuff you guys mess around with it a bit
last night I don't really need gun oh
the way I'm playing with this scavenger
is probably better but I don't live long
enough some
you who says play is nomads next nomads
all right let's not do that sure we we
play with well we'll get the Doge out
there
heck yeah yeah it is a good thing they
don't have loot boxes or season passes
right
can you stop you use can you use what
stopping power mp40 round drum and p40
the mp40 i doubt is in this game but if
it is I'd be waiting for tea that's
that's that's a call back to World War 2
I want to get this gun what up why Oh
cuz of the merry thing ah can you use
the other studio okay how long do you
think you're gonna go in there I don't
usually go in till 45 they don't usually
go until 10:45 I'll tell them that it
was my fault Thanks whoops there we go
that's a thing no oh it did it anyways
hey you got mono drafted it knew you it
knew all right whatever we're gonna use
the SMG I guess until i can switch
glasses good yeah so the main thing you
gotta like I don't know let's try it out
here you go do that and do that and then
now it's touched and it's like you know
ooh
the room was out follow that thing it's
an easy kill it shock somebody like
there you go just like that
that thing feels a little like that it
takes too long to kill that thing from
like a if you're trying to save your
buddy what the hell is that
tell Mike we said hello Mike's already
gone he's a man on a mission
yeah I had a big whoopsies moment
oh yeah that was bad how did he head
shot me oh there's a black ops pass
which is like a season pass okay okay
it's a four-on-four
swim that's why I like doing this with a
live stream I don't know a thing you
guys you guys got my back yes it was
worth I don't care right we're yes so
now I think better and it was because of
that assault pack so you got we got 25
more points because of the assault pack
okay very nice that's a pretty yep I
should drop shot at him there it is
bring it back
I do also agree with red space that it's
nice that the specialists are all in
logs right now right now hope that
carries over cause it'd be nice to just
have everything available to God if I
did get that that would have been judged
by the stream it's you back on that s
e-g life and everything makes sense it's
weird though like everything makes I was
I was playing a more feathery accurate
game or trying to earlier and now like
it's you just go that's all gone out the
window to the wall to the ghetto why
weren't you there sooner my little
friend can't believe this
hi guys new the stream will welcome red
I hope you have a good time while we're
sitting here playing some Call of Duty
uh oh they're on the other side there's
a ton of livestream stuff happening
today too
if you guys haven't subscribed to the
channel yet be sure to do that so you
don't miss a single one we're going to
be doing last last GameSpot daily later
on today
and also we're going to be doing one of
our first community playdate things
where we're gonna be playing some Dragon
Ball Fighter Z with you guys so if you
want to hand our asses to us if I don't
wear today oh I got someone be sure to
show up we're gonna celebrate Evo and
talk about what we're we're stoked to
watch for tonight God welcome as well on
the beach in the open
how's the Battle Royale got a chance to
play but there's gonna be a beta 400 job
trotty didn't work change your emblem I
don't think you can't can can't yeah
you're right
Oh guys I got triple on us look at the
draw if you get one that's cool you get
one that's cool in the beta at least
which platform will be playing on ps4 oh
my goodness oh oh we gotta kill that
Kobe's got she sees gonna call
Activision and tell them that you're
doing too well right now Tay that's
equal stuff out I don't know about that
I'll take it just never go down Main
Street ever like oh go get him whoo oh
yeah at pupper all right I'm follow you
what do you smell what do you see
where's the a boy why why are you so
fast yikes oh he's up he off you got
someone oh that's a good dog
all right where where are you going that
was so quick though huh hey don't you
dare alright hey yeah yeah Ana AR is
melee still using the buttstock back to
Rio melee it's still blood stock that's
that's one of the things I don't like
about the newer Call of Duty's is it's
not a one hit there is legit sorry to
cut you off there is legit like
weird-ass Wow were you really sign on
the corner there is oh my dog he's in a
Doge there's weird like collision like
if you slide into someone you actually
like bounce off of them which is like
frickin weird yeah but if fur I guess
for hopes for the the melee stuff I
think you can actually get a TAC knife
attachment for the pistol which might
whoa so tech nice might be back I think
I saw that in the menu
we'll have to check for that yeah
definitely the old tec-9 with lunch
no no lunch that was a fun time though
today
ones the pc beta drop next week next
week next Friday next Friday - well if
you're seeing framedrops it might be the
stream it looks like it's pretty smooth
over here at least just watching like is
it just one person saying that or is it
like everyone you try changing the
resolution on the player right so I up
the bitrate today as an experiment so
I'm not sure if that's causing in one
problems to you but sorry if it is
obviously I do like the maybe I don't
like it it's really weird like the
random things the characters will say
when they're in the middle of I like
doing stuff oh yeah
cuz i play recon all the time whenever
anyone steps into like the zone like
he'll just i'll be randomly running
somewhere and he'll just whispered to
himself we see you i'm like why would
you do this why are you Sykes you got
you with a pistol - both of them and I
just choked it like oh hi one of the
zombies B to come out I don't think
there's gonna be a Zion day to ever do
zombies beta I'm some of the top that's
good oh man I'm not close to a dog I
need another dog What did he say shut up
shoutout oh we don't want to go down
Main Street okay there's a guy in this
room oh yeah you have an RC car he must
had Rika pulls up because he was pre
firing this [ __ ] I don't know what you
got from your care on my arches yeah I
hate that thing dude it's actually not
easy to drive oh please please kill him
he had no life what's a potato Mode
potato mode is the series that our good
pal Joey does every week where he just
makes beautiful games look excellent man
horribly awful oh you just did one right
yeah it just went up
where we we actually used a mod on top
of making the graphics look really bad
for Metal Gear Solid 5 so if you like
Metal Gear and you like low settings on
graphics and giant spinning revolvers
ocelots there's a video for you I don't
think we're gonna get another dog
because I'm now how many times can you
revive yourself to full health and a
life so if you're talking about just
healing with the actual like injector
it's it's pretty quick but yeah it's not
like you could spam it right away
yeah hang a wreath on just say like I'll
let you know at least you just dipped
said no more of this that's not good
there's a hailstorm coming here you only
got one person guitar player he wants to
let you know what he's about you know so
metal you're on the switch that is
usually the the joke if you are curious
what many of your solid 5 might look
like right now on the switch
check out potato mode yeah it's true
oh he's got to be upset about that I
would be yeah well you know Oh miss on
switch no this is on the PlayStation 4
entertainment console it does have kind
of a crisis look especially on this map
because it's like tropical should not
have it's over we lost you jinxed it Ben
you know I'm just kidding
you got it you've got to lose sometimes
to appreciate supered me yeah it's fine
still number one waiting for that to be
the play of the game just the singular
use it's a dog like the dog of ghost I
don't know I feel like sometimes I don't
know what the hell is doing like it got
two kills that I'm like I don't he's so
fast I can't use all Thirsty's you see
the the metal that's that's what it was
show off the snipers or is this a
personal stream I mean I can try
just watch the chat get upset once I
start sniping that's all I got that I'm
just putting it out there it's it's it's
the it's the argument of when you're
streaming of this guys having a good
time yeah yes it's the argument of do
you show people gameplay that's you know
people getting shot and like actually
being able play the game or do you go
and show people things that they want to
see because they're curious this has a
fire fire it says straight damage but
run the risk of not doing this I guess
well that's a real risky guys real risky
well we got a flak jacket Oh enemy
explosives nobody cares about that oh
dang where's that do they have the
double primary as a thing I think so
it's got a question how do we feel about
the like the game's pace as a whole
compared to other call duties I feel
like it's still quick but it's faster
yeah like you're not gonna be jumping
off walls or anything
it's it's a good a good quick time speed
is Center precision accuracy while abs
okay well we don't have that yet we
probably need like a shotgun or
something
[Music]
there you go that's the other angle for
the sniping is entertaining what if you
save shots
how many shots can we not hit how many
times can we shoot like around the
person's head and have them kind of like
spin around looking where we're coming
from all right here we go
we'll try it one game cuz I actually
don't like sniping
yeah I can't snipe to save my hand I'm
not afraid to admit it it's not it's not
my um it's not my forte let's just say
that back to octopus octopus is a good
time I I haven't gotten a chance to
start it yet though but from what I've
seen and what I've heard real good time
do both to appease the curious and if
he's the others don't worry you're about
to you're about to see it we're doing it
we're done it for you I won't stir a
disclaimer that if mid-match I'm really
just having a hell of a time all right
we'll just plain old you've got the the
hatchet - oh that takes it up my actual
thing oh that's not good looks fine I
would rather have the mine so I can just
type you have a loadout like fit for a
montage right now okay so like oh sorry
my sensitivity is too low
oh god I choked that one already know
how do they do it they're just like it's
like a there's not enough spinning
happening oh yeah I got a hold down to
breathe that's what it was yep mm-hmm
I don't know why I took the shot
considering there was no way in hell
Waddy armor hello
yeah yeah Oh God uh I'll get him with
the hatchet you're gonna follow him up
yeah yeah I deserve it I can't believe I
should use the other sniper maybe then
yeah all right I got a I got a hold the
l3 for the breathe MLG 360 noscope
you got it there's no three six go like
that quick scope you like that quick
scope I've got an action hatchet at him
so you got to remember that you got the
hatchet because it there is it
possibility not only for sniper kills
- maybe happen but also hatchet kills
see up here right there it is right in
the back we can hit up fire break after
this Liam yeah when I actually am like
running around and stuff yeah well I was
bad feeling behind this
I got quick scope I got quick scope I
got quick scope that's what it was
I should have hatcheted like I don't
remember I got it I'm literally have my
button on r1 right now come on just
constantly thinking about come on
I got a hatchet with someone's name on
it Oh oh my god it's so slow it's so
slow you like can you like cook it like
hold it I don't know some question cuz I
feel like that might be the best way to
do like just run around with you ought
to do uh like a melee only run or I'm
just gonna use my fist I don't know why
reloading who see that might be the
thing that makes me use a sniper more as
if I put a different sight on it I know
this is the bass one so if you like this
one well you just leave like la for it
so it's it's more of like yeah dude
maybe you has a sniper you should just
be able to should just be able to get
rid of your heal cuz when am I really
ever gonna heal I feel like I'm just
gonna die before I this fair you know
what since if you plan if you mess with
your sensitive now base I think it's for
one more hit up he's never gonna peak
again right Ajax after fire break
alright yeah yep body armor Oh
okay yeah okay came for you and he did I
missed two shots it was it was deserved
I love snipers Oh what's your opinion on
the graphics this year I like how they
have more color or it seems like things
are more saturated other than that like
the art style is kind of like the weird
future but not future kind of semi
believable down the line kind of I'm
really into the saturation though 0.6
this is the life of a sniper actually
now I probably would have got like at
least one or two more kills at my age
those 40 times skills just make it so
it's impossible to see anything else but
what you're aiming at what does call
duties version of battle royale entail I
think the the details on all of it are
still kind of like scarce but we had
that teaser trailer like a week ago
thank goodness there you go so you're
kind of getting into it no no look it
feels like there was a guy right there
that's not a peek
shoot'em his back is literally to you
and you die yeah okay
see I need the mines so that I would
have heard it go off you know and then I
could have escaped yeah we're we're
definitely not set up for like
professional sniping with our and not
even amateur sniping okay we're not set
up for sniping we're doing this so
people can all get nowadays chopped up
we got everything we came here for
the shotguns actually pretty good real
talk
it ain't bad that's for sure I was
diggin it was messing around with it
yesterday how's the game compared to
world war two I think I like it more
than World War two but then again I've
only played this beta for a couple hours
and I played through most of everything
that World War two had to offer so I'll
hold my verdict often so I play more of
the game but multiplayer wise I mean I'm
enjoying this
[Music]
Ricardo thank you for telling me to
snipe I love it so much hail Mary are
you guys excited for zombies yeah Shawn
very excited
they put a map on the Titanic I can get
my axe back everything I've always
wanted random throw yo get my axe back
oh you can actually pick it up yeah
uh what is ha oh and I dude he just got
triple let's play again feels good feels
good I threw my axe
that's a flashbang I woke up and I was
dead
oh that dog it's not a good sound it'll
look a pupper I can't I can't
yeah this is what you wanted 360 slow
scope guy that crime that slow scope
life oh shut me up repose hey Trey hope
you're having a good day thank you for
for subbing hanging out no Mary no I
felt that it was gonna happen I got
really excited I was like oh could it
all the maps better than last year
they're very corridor II but I I kind of
like them still the amount of how like
the how much there your device it's kind
of worries but you know definitely low
impact yeah but yeah you were there
showed up we're doing some things I feel
like after like the first like maybe
minute and a half at bullet whizzed by
him yeah use LMG know what is this do
this we're getting the quick hits just
hit it off this man fire break LMG
alright alright fire break LMG I got a
make a class for it it's what I wanted
it and it's what I love yeah but it's
such a it's ok as a personal as a person
that watches a lot of like different you
know gameplay videos montages it feels
bad to watch bad sniping person that's
why I don't subscribe to China like show
people that's sniper we know that the
people who watched you guys watch the
slowest barrel
maybe it's better because we're talking
and were able to be like hey guys look
understand that this is not what we do
but we're doing it because you want to
see it may be that having it beforehand
because if we put up a video of just
sniper gameplay without any commentary
on it I guarantee it would not be
alright OMG here's your LMG Titan will
go and we'll just leave shotguns mine
I'm gonna put body armor on
is it hard to snipe it's hard it's hard
for us to snipe because we're not
snipers a good sniper I'm not a good
aimer so I need to spray a bit okay god
heavy oh but then if I do this then I
can't have the thing is that what it is
I think so yeah what they have put it
you gotta have an attachment for that
shotgun now right I have no optics of a
stock or stock yeah that'll help I don't
know okay so there's a operator mods -
Oh suppressive your suppressive barrel
I wonder what like if the suppressing
actually what are you suppress why would
you suppress a LMG oh no it's not it's
not a suppressor so it makes it so that
like I'm guessing if you're shooting at
people who are like hiding behind things
it'll like make it so they can't see
your name very well so it's more of a
suppressing fire than a suppressed
weapon wet water I don't think we give
me a cotton even a 9 in like a long time
you know take that with whatever you
want to say how's the certainly game can
you hear footsteps like in other better
Royal Games because they'll have a
battle royale mode I'm curious if it'll
be different I haven't really like
there's a lot of sound go around say
don't hear steps too much but time to
kill is weird in this game it's too long
it's just different it's longer than
usual for sure and that's why I'm saying
like SMG currently just seems to give
you more room for air suppress LMGs are
beasts ETA okay
I'll take your word for it oh my fire
break my break you all right so I get
the fire thing and then I get a
flamethrower right essentially I think
so yeah I feel good about this it's
gonna be this could be a good match I
got to hold it down to put down this
area denial thing we're going to the
wine cellar well you have to hold it I
like how you have to put a thing to tell
you to hold it that's good I wouldn't
have known I'm gonna regret my decision
here which is good it's so slow buggy or
whatever it's real punch Eve oh no I
stink
what could I could have had a good
moment there the lad more content to it
right undeniably I guarantee there's
gonna be DLC for this are you guys going
to play fallout 76 beat-up yes yes there
are a lot of us were very excited for it
can't wait to see what it's all about I
get up here
rest assured we'll share experiences
with you that we flipped we flipped this
is such a stupid spot I died up here to
someone come on
show the stream how good this spot is
we're just we're just whipping them too
hard
sure back into the fray yeah from where
I don't put that that the heat thing
down right in the middle everything all
right Wow oh you just kind of like I
don't know what was going on oh man I
there's a meter that popped up how did
he switch guns so fast I don't know yeah
I don't know how that one works unless
maybe everyone around me gets like
thinned you know I mean maybe it's like
if someone's hiding behind a box you can
do like it like it's like an AoE that
goes like Jerry you I'm superhuman this
is not how you should be playing an LMG
probably I just think of the campaign
being removable we miss it we touched on
it a little bit earlier but we both feel
like we're okay with the campaign being
gone I don't know what just happened
it was it I guess because drop shot but
like wow yeah we're we're gonna miss it
but we're also all right they're not
gone too sad about it there's enough
content I think in this that it'll be
all right
fish mine smoked through the door yep
you're still using those iron sights
that doesn't matter it's just a slow
plodding
I guess all right I gotta get my head in
the game it's fine you can make any gun
work Wow
maybe I can't uh that's good though I
like that
oh we got him reactor ready to go
critical sorry we got you to get
critical what do you I don't know I
radiated him or something what I don't
know he can't heal he can heal he can't
heal is what it is I think okay right
that's what happened to me earlier might
be it oh oh we lost this again
what why we're back everything's fine
that was you drop shotting try hard
I'm not alright yeah happy to shut you
out happier here Trey happy I don't know
why that happened I'm glad you guys
chose to hang out with us on this
wonderful Friday
my foots not even close to the to the
HDMI it just it felt the height from you
using this light machine gun and it was
just too much
oh yeah I'm less than that glued the
bass kick from those those real intense
rounds just cause every when you get
jostled around in here
like what was that he like slide jokes
no see awkward you jump like this
what so you you jump into a slide it'll
actually let you like do it all in one
motion or something from one of the tips
it was trying to say maybe you're not
working for me it's like full sprint for
it to do a thing but okay hitmarkers
doesn't matter is the knife one shot I
haven't gotten it yet so I'm not sure
can I not quite I assume that the knife
is one shot I hope the knife is one shot
because if it's not it's a little time
what kind of headset are we using what
are these get irradiated what oh oh I
tried to do the thing they're just Sony
studio MDR isn't it okay I'm gonna get a
hitmarker on them and then get a get
some points for it yeah world war ii add
some pretty here alright i did something
i world war ii head had great sound
it had josh duhamel i got art world war
ii four limbs are new alright real slow
to kill yeah oh god that's that's about
what i expect a flamethrower to do
that's kind of why i haven't used them
very much I'm sure there's more
application outside of TDM
yeah I'm talking about the the mainly to
I hope that the I'm so sorry I'm like so
sorry dog the actual just Meili itself
so the regular mainly is just with the
butt of your gun so it's not a one hand
because but you can unlock from the back
it is though from the back you can
unlock early attack knife attachment for
the pistol and that's why I thought you
were talking right
oh he must have shot him twice with his
tempest yeah I was trying to do the
melee from behind there your dog I'm on
a high ground you can't Oh No oh god I'm
so sorry I'm sorry I'm glad you didn't
kill that dog Oh what the hell is a
rampart what is this oh I've never seen
this gun I think it's the second assault
no the second let's offer Abel's the can
and whatever oh you're right maybe it's
the third one this is the ball it does
not do damage get LMG okay we're flip
sides again yeah with all these max just
said the LMG using songs like so many
smashing sausage against the wall
repeatedly ah J is actually pretty
accurate what we should just do up like
a video feature that's like ah what does
this guy sound like sausage slapping a
wall this one sounds like someone's
slapping mud alright is there any other
requests before I can go back to playing
mostly normal nomad least I want you to
use just punching fists as the bearded
one
I wanna fight but you gotta use the
tomahawk topping I can't I'll bury him
just punch and everything hmm
punch everything Tay well we might as
well put every perk on extended mags on
something Oh God
reflex I extended mags like because yeah
you need to extend it you can and what
do you want me to do take taken SMG as a
backup in case everything just doesn't
go well okay unequip the shotgun so you
can do whatever you got to do for
everything else and then use the
tomahawk we already have okay just set
this up for like what you'd want to do
and we'll try we'll try punching and
then you just fall back out of this and
we'll play as a character that we
haven't played yet oh it says um what's
this one oh there is nothing we do
shotgun only after this if tazed into it
Johnny but I'm making him do a real dumb
thing right now
we just did this site I guess there you
go alright this is gonna be a hell of a
time which bearded guy there's a couple
there's two bearded three borderline two
and a half there are a couple bearded
guys which bearded guy we not played it
before I haven't done ruin yet oh but
see but I lose the grappling hook if I
use the tomahawk that's why I was like
you know what uh pick him use the
grapple gun instead of the tomahawk then
you can just like grapple around you can
make this real intense there you go hey
so you can put the tritium site you can
grapple you grapple around now and punch
people so your quick your mobile your
Angeles it's real stupid all right
what they came to see right now this is
just what I'm telling you to do they no
one said anything about it I just want
to know if it's a viable option I mean
if you preorder you get a code I don't
know how soon that is if you are an
Xfinity member you can get a code other
than that I'm not sure how else you get
a code right now we were doing giveaway
but we might have ran out of codes
already yeah do you can check on the
site see what's going on with that but
am I allowed to abandon ship on this
idea if it goes literally sour that's
why I said like have the SMG and if
you're like nah this isn't doing it for
me we're gonna get we're gonna get
murked
do the thing I wish the fists were one
hit that would make it at least
appealing but you're you're more ready
to punch someone so you're just gonna
knock him out
it picked crash for me that's not a
thing here we go here we go all right
good luck us just think you got that
grapple hook yeah you do min behind
someone you just punch him in the back
of the head it'll be great that's
progress that means it can work we can
get in sorry teammates this is Ben's
idea so I'll give you give you the five
deathrun at this
you have five five attempts to try and
punch out a guy you're already two in so
you don't even have to do it that long
no no no I try for a bit okay try for a
bit I'll try I really wish it if if
you're just on fist though that it could
just oh it is okay it is are too sweet
artoo is right and l2 is left I think
left is quicker where are you yeah well
there it is
yeah heck yeah no no I don't want to be
there you you unlocked something for
that I did what a spider can oh no no he
doesn't blinded me I suppose the next
one we're gonna do Ajax with a shot dude
that's yeah that's so stupid my punches
should not be like being influenced by
his body armor
it should just straight up to hit yeah
Treyarch please I think you think of all
the people who want to main punching in
black ops poor punched your body armor
please dude that the slide into punch is
like it's the shorter it's even shorter
like um it's like I don't know that's
about the same dude I feel like I got
t-rex arms yeah they're not very long
there's not much reach there but maybe
maybe you should start doing left I
swear the left punch is quicker oh it is
sir
we're punch there we were there sir I'm
trying to do a thing was one all we
could hope for
nah man there's so much there's still
time left in this match
Dewi go sit on you completely what where
did he go then why that's right the
melee melee main life is real hard I
don't get it
oh you know you can grapple kill someone
though I think oh really I think so I
don't know how much damage you wish you
could use a grapple and a tomahawk at
the same time you might be able to I
don't know maybe like you did a good job
giving instruction for the other guy no
sorry Chad oh man we got one we got one
which it means it's possible dude that
kind of you know what my ghost did on me
though or or I just I don't know it's
something weird happened then haha like
that can't pull my soul towards it like
you do like like a scorpion yeah I do
you get over here that'd be real cool
how could you put a grappling hook in
the game and not be able to pull people
a left it definitely feels faster yeah
but this is my strong arm this is the
haymaker gotcha
oh this could be a bad idea if that's
theirs
woo that frame drop a lot of them hey
hey hey all right I can't I can't do
this anymore man all right hey I'm
utterly point one Kady you got one kill
that's good now now we bring it back and
we save the day okay you're only 15
kills behind everything's gonna be fine
all whoa there it is
Wow those are just so good I know how to
play a game now
please tell me that saved me that would
be awesome if it saved me
oh yeah no idea where the hell I am
dammit dude that flash lasts forever
yeah oh is that that one guys um
concussion grenade maybe possible
because that's his like special
equipment thing hey there's totally a
dude behind you isolate into oh no guys
walking around with a shield I think
this is just team deathmatch right
yeah we're just eating because that's
like the fastest like can you get over
no yes I think most people are in team
deathmatch right now there are three
modes that you can play in the beta but
this is this is a quicker one for sure
that would have been a melee time I
think I was trying to get a drink from
the vending machine yeah I know sorry
not sorry
oh that was just a real not good time or
the best time
you did dude his super is not that great
Titan smash would have killed him both
because it would have like cleared the
wall you're like just totally a guy down
here unless they traded
shut out enemy UAV above that's not good
what why are you there everyone we're
starting to get into working and they're
all like oh hey what's going on we got
these things going on I need to publish
I'm not publishing stuff so I'm also
covering for guys somehow despite me
actually playing we've done we've gotten
a lower score or like we're even farther
behind playing guy there oh there's
three guys here
all that guys got a bit on fire or
something what did we get irradiated I
don't know how that I don't know how
that thing works so I'm just gonna say
yeah I should it did a much better job
there though to be honest could I had
three kills don't shoot the dog
bad bad on you sir my flip sides I just
wanted to grab all I just want to
grapple I sort of fix my score
we're from point one to point nine
that's you almost brought it up - OH -
one for one after doing only melee kills
with your fists oh that was me
I would say like the pace in terms of
movement is close you just don't get the
jet blue stuff but yeah like the running
around this stuff is so like pretty fast
in the maps are not that big it's still
three lanes I pretty much never go down
middle even though I still go down
middle it's just like I mean we're
streaming at 60 it might be YouTube
compression then so I like watching it
right now it's just running pretty well
mm-hmm we got time for like one more
match one more besides we've got some
stuff to do anyways we got a strike team
I don't think we're ever gonna we also
got the SM or the so we're gonna do boy
do you want to do it since it's the last
match you might just want to do what you
want to do Oh cuz I got to do the Ajax
thing unless you want to do that I'd say
I say like do the last one up the way
that you want to do it okay set up that
class pick your your your Jermaine dude
no attachments rapidfire is so good
though it is it's very good let's just
get rid of this okay
sorry folks we're gonna have to do it
what I want it I'll play profit we have
a play profit and I actually profit so
okay so the only ones we didn't play is
a jack sorry
that's the 9 bang see now that's what
was getting me I think real bad powerful
stun grenade
we don't play battery and Seraph I think
great everyone else we played sounds
about right if you preorder now can you
still get in the beta I would assume so
but I think so I don't know I don't
think they'd cut it off I want to watch
someone who interacts with our audience
we're trying James sorry that you don't
feel that that might not be happening
yeah we're talking to you dig deep
try to go ham I'm into it if you want I
got the silence I switch to the straight
class but I would have to kind of camp
that out I think to get that high of a
kill streak the strike force dudes I
have so much life really
yeah and allotted a whole clip into it
and it did not mean they did not die and
I think they dropped two of them was it
worth buying hard to say we're only
playing the multiplayer and we're not
even we haven't tried blackout yet
either so there's so much this game
that's not in this beta for people you
can't make like a definitive call this
is only on ps4 at the moment yes I
believe so does he just like toss that
thing out with both of his hands yeah oh
[ __ ] it's done somebody but on the right
it's okay Oh
he's done you guys are doing well Thank
You Lucas
we're trying I appreciate it
see underneath suburb and the beta does
not come with Battle Royale
shredded September but there is a
separate beta than that in September for
it has some G's though at some Jesus oh
I love it and a silencer and the assault
pack all helping right now oh definitely
it was there I felt a yeah she got the
double though yeah I got care package to
commence UAV surveillance operation
oh yeah count on whenever the The
Blackout beta goes live we'll be doing
that it'll be a fun time hopefully oh
this is a bad spot I don't know why I
did that
so this is like me chokepoint Roomba go
go come go do a thing guys go engage
well I wonder if that you think it oh no
job well it doesn't have the parachute
anymore I'll counter UAV garbage thanks
for nothing
it's it's points it gives you points Wow
by the way now having the suppressor it
makes a pretty big difference yeah hello
oh I was shooting for the recon thing
but here have a counter you're on I
shouldn't do it actually should probably
wait and hope that they get a UAV even
though they probably won't yeah
you're coming from anywhere oh I got my
tempest ready holy [ __ ] alright let's do
a jury you're doing pretty pretty well
right now this thing is like pretty slow
though oh my god I'd go destroy censor
yes I would like to destroy censor no
wonder they knew what I'm not done
anything with this thing see people
don't heal they don't like think it's
not in like people's instinct yet to
heal yes still a new thing I just want
to shock somebody please did you get the
guy that I stunned assume he did cuz he
he's still alive was still alive sure
maybe you'll give me something better
this time here I have a counter UAV yeah
we can have a UAV too this is the most
this is the most I've gotten like ever
though oh sweet another UAV alright well
that's actually like UAV though you v's
good it it's the the best it's the best
kill streak in the game I just stole
your kill sorry not sorry
are you a bee's gone already here if the
blackout beta is included in this later
honor if if this gets updated to it I
assume the PC bait is probably gonna
work the same way but yeah black out all
we know is that we had the one teaser
for it we know it exists basically so
I'm sure we'll get more information
coming up on when the beta is supposed
to happen
and push how do you change your calling
card and stuff I don't think you can in
the beta chilling like a villain you get
a chance to turn around that's what I
want no chances men in there I stopped
shooting what man I shouldn't have
looked at my KD just now it's like oh
yeah I'm probably pretty good now it's
all plummeting yep got mine guess so and
enemy halt storm detected get the hell
inside dude we were smashing them what
the hell happened people must have just
joined started slaying out guests love
that drop thank you sue unless that
already had damage that was very fast
compared to like some of the other stuff
that's for sure but it is just a little
satellite dish so I think it has more
uptime to
got to be moving got to always be moving
in cod what they got a tact chopper uh
when's the beta over I think it's over
the end of the weekends not entirely
sure I saw the date earlier but I don't
so when you get shocked there's a chance
to press you can still shoot and stuff
too so think you can actually press a
button maybe break out of it oh really
because like when it happens like a the
square button pops up like that's four
seconds
that poor guy oh no no no I just wanted
to UAV someone shoot that chopper down
yeah everyone's interested in World War
three
the game came out of nowhere UAV got
destroyed what someone's actually
shooting rockets to I'm a tempest again
should we just yellow do it yeah thinks
died with it I shocked you to let you on
fire yeah that's alright it's he's still
ticking right now it's true I can get
there he's out there sweet sweet SMG
life how do the gun seem okay yeah isn't
pretty good from the ones that I've used
I think tase I have a Roomba
what came by just pushed you away I
tried to I try it because I knew there
are people there okay have a careful as
saying that yeah I think you've used
more guns than I have so you can
probably
suppress now I am living a dream right
now or it feels like I'm living a dream
thank you there's a guy out there that
could shoot me I just want this assault
pack movie streaming with new spider-man
game you betcha but didn't you watch me
play spider-man just now yeah we here
have a care package
20 seconds oh there it is good a care
package shop
we're playing TDM but there are two
other modes on top of thank you I don't
know what this is
do it do a thing where are the bad guys
they don't exist
dang I was the best round I could play
for you guys there
well you guys were man down to no good
wasn't even me dang it oh that's me
dying though perfect um yeah I mean cod
is always a cod time yeah that's how I
look at it I I do like the health pack
though I actually like yeah that it's a
little bit slower to kill someone
I do wish for better gun what am i
what's the word I'm looking for riot II
not variety balancing yeah gun balancing
in that in that like I wish the SMGs
weren't so good gun do anything to bring
about gun variety
I feel like matches I feel like smg's
you can do you can shoot the SMG too far
like to accurately at you bar like it
should dominate short maybe mid-range
but you saw me shooting like pretty long
distances with it and I feel like that's
where the AR should have a leg up
because they shoot so slow compared to
an SMG but definitely you know I'm sure
they'll figure it out or you know hey
it's still caught so yeah some G's kind
of you know I'm sure someone will figure
some stuff out though but I like the
specialist they feel pretty good you
know play the one that you you like are
the ones that might help your team crash
is obviously good support recon also a
good kind of support but yeah thanks so
much Ben thank you for hanging out I
think we'll try as well next Friday to
stream PC because that'll be out okay DP
saying Evo tonight yeah looking forward
to it Evos a fun time
a little sad that I'm not there but I am
happy that to watch it you know when I
can at my leisure leader and yeah you
got streams today too
yeah we got streams in about a half an
hour we're gonna have the last GameSpot
daily Kelly Michael gonna give you the
the hot news of the day and maybe some
fun times along the way so tune in for
that and then right after that John Luke
and I are going to be playing Street not
street fighter fighter dragon like
dragons fighter
dragon dragon ball fighters with you
guys on the ps4 talking about Evo
hanging out and having a good time come
beat us up because he's not too evil
will be on by then fine not yet huh not
exactly start I feel like it might pulls
might be starting what it's hard to say
what it is yeah we're gonna have a fun
time hanging out playing some fighting
games with you guys talking about what
we're excited to see Devo and it should
be good times all right
um yeah that was cod blopps for black
ops 4 multiplayer beta stay tuned again
spot obviously for more cod stuff yeah
and PC be out next week as well take it
easy everybody yeah have a good Friday
see you back soon oh yeah get hype see
see ya crash is good specialist I was
hoping
[Music]